foreign
[Music]
this week we have again prepared all
kinds of news about movies and series
for you in this video included is Avatar
3 a possible signing of Jason Momoa into
the MCU a movie adaptation of the
popular game series Rainbow Six as well
as news about the finale of the anime
Attack on Titan you can also look
forward to news about the sequel to the
horror film Megan and an overview of all
the films that will be released
exclusively on Netflix this year we hope
you enjoy our new video
Avatar the way of water might well
become the most successful movie of all
time that should please director James
Cameron and Disney in particular after
all it was not clear for a long time
whether the high production costs would
ever be covered and whether they would
go ahead with the planned sequels now
that the movie is paying off reports
about the sequel Avatar 3 are increasing
this week producer John Landau who was
always in active exchange with the media
gave an interview to Empire magazine one
of the topics was a Hollywood star who
by all accounts will not be appearing in
the sequels after all in 2019 a video
appeared on social media showing Fast
and Furious actor Vin Diesel on camera
with James Cameron on set diesel spoke
of how he would love to work with
Cameron giving the impression that he
would take on a role in the upcoming
films in a later interview with
Entertainment Tonight diesel elaborated
on his statement and confirmed his
involvement in Avatar since then nothing
more has been said about it
and also in the currently running film
there was nothing to be seen or heard of
him this week producer Landau denied
Diesel's involvement and clarified the
situation it was all just a big
misunderstanding Vin Diesel had merely
stopped by the set as a big fan of the
series and wanted to take a look at the
production therefore a role in one of
the sequels is out of the question which
is why many fans are now asking
themselves why diesel made contradictory
statements beforehand and rightly so we
are eager to find out whether Landau is
now deliberately causing confusion only
to bring diesel to Avatar later on or
whether the plans with him may have been
discarded after a brief collaboration
and they don't want to make this public
further news is available on the
specific plot of the upcoming films in a
conversation with Edith Bowman on her
podcast director James Cameron announced
that Jake Sully will no longer play the
role of the narrator instead his son
moack who had a bigger role in the
second part will become the behind the
scenes Storyteller in the upcoming third
part this is said to be primarily
because loac has been especially well
received by fans in Avatar 4 and 5 the
storytellers will then change again
however it is not clear yet who they are
going to be but first of all Avatar 3
will be released on December 20th 2024
rumored to be titled Avatar the seed
Bearer have you already seen the second
movie and if so what is your view on
avatar the way of water let us know in
the comments
Megan has only recently been thrilling
many horror fans at the movies as the
first major movie of the genre in 2023
it has so far been able to bring in well
over 100 million US Dollars setting the
bar very high for upcoming movies after
some rumors shortly before release a
sequel is now officially in the works
the hit film is about an artificial
intelligence that is built into a creepy
doll originally it was supposed to help
little Katie overcome her loneliness but
the longer Megan is around the more
cruel and deadly it becomes a return of
Alison Williams and violet McGraw in the
starring roles has already been
confirmed and the official title Megan
2.0 has also been announced whether the
sequel can be as convincing as the
original will only become clear in just
about two years the release date is set
for January 17 2025.
the aftermath of James gunns and Peter
safran's decision to completely revamp
the DC Universe is clearly noticeable
while many actors such as Gal Gadot as
Wonder Woman or Henry cavillis Superman
have already been dropped others are
expected to remain with DC Jason Momoa
belongs to the latter category as it was
assumed that he would play a different
role after the big changes namely that
of the alien Bounty Hunter Lobo as giant
freaking robot reported this week
however he is now to take a completely
new route and move to the competitor
Marvel negotiations are reportedly
currently underway for the role of Ben
Grimm aka the Bing who has already been
played by Michael Bailey Smith Michael
Chiklis and Jamie Bell in other films in
fact Grimm meets a comparatively tragic
theme as he has turned into a stone
monster with no chance of returning to
his human form in return as a member of
the Fantastic Four he is extremely
strong and has his heart in the right
place there is no official confirmation
from Marvel or Mamoa yet but we are
expecting more news assume Fantastic
Four is scheduled to hit theaters on
February 14 2025.
Netflix is not inactive this year either
when it comes to exclusive movies for
the streaming services subscribers there
will be a total of 16 films which almost
always include Top Class actors it'll
soon kick off with your place or mine on
February 10th where things are supposed
to get romantic the film stars Reese
Witherspoon and Ashton Kutcher who play
best friends Debbie and Peter they live
on both coasts of the USA and swap homes
for a week Netflix is streaming year
2023 continues with murder mystery 2
starring Adam Sandler and Jennifer
Aniston which should particularly appeal
to Crime fans the previous film was
released in 2019 and scored over 80
million views in its first few weeks we
can't wait to find out how the sequel is
received this summer we'll see the
release of extraction 2 which follows on
from its predecessor released in 2020
and Promises plenty of action once again
on June 16th fans of the first part will
be able to see Chris Hemsworth in the
leading role again a highlight towards
the end of the year is Zack Rebel Moon
the content is about a human Colony at
the edge of the Galaxy that is
threatened by the army of a tyrannical
ruler Sophia boutella takes on the lead
role of the warrior Korra having last
appeared in Guillermo del Toro's Cabinet
of Curiosities among the films announced
for 2023 there are still two entries
without a concrete release date among
them is a still Untitled film by Wes
Anderson based on the short story
collection the wonderful story of Henry
sugar and six more by Roald Dahl so the
title of the film adaptation is expected
to be similar another movie without a
release date is the biographical drama
Maestro with Bradley Cooper
simultaneously directing and starring as
Leonard Bernstein Bernstein who died in
1990 is widely regarded as one of the
most talented and successful pianists in
U.S history he composed the music for
the musical West Side Story for example
all in all Netflix has some very
promising films among the 16
announcements and we are curious to see
how these films with a top class fast
will perform for a complete overview of
the new releases we recommend checking
out the news article on the kenocheck
website where we have compiled all of
the upcoming movies
the Japanese anime Attack on Titan has
been running since 2013 and has so far
managed to impress many fans around the
globe the series revolves around the
young Aaron Yeager who witnesses his
hometown being destroyed and his mother
being killed he bows revenge and makes
it his mission to free the Earth from
the gigantic humanoid Titans who are
responsible for the destruction
currently the series is in the midst of
the final fourth season which has been
regularly expanded since December of
2020 after a year of waiting since the
last episode those responsible now
published a trailer via Twitter as well
as the information that the ultimate
finale of the last season will be
released in two parts there are also
persistent rumors that a feature film
will be released after the end of the
fourth season which will then finally
bring the series to a close starting on
March 4th 2023 we'll know more as the
first part of the finale will then be
released which will certainly provide
answers to some questions the present
format is rumored to change as well so
we can possibly expect a total of only
two more long episodes
game developer Ubisoft achieved a huge
financial success with the first person
shooter Rainbow Six Siege the fun online
gaming experience still attracts
millions of players worldwide to the
screen today more than seven years after
its release so it's not surprising that
there are thoughts of an adaptation to
the big screen especially since a
veritable flood of game adaptations has
been hitting audiences for the past few
years most recently HBO's The Last of Us
celebrated its successful series debut
now it seems that the right man has been
found to direct a Rainbow Six movie
namely none other than John Wick
director Chad stachelski the movie will
be based on the 1998 novel of the same
name by thriller author Tom Clancy and
will also star Michael B Jordan the
latter is to portray the lead character
John Clark who has already made
appearances in various games Clark is a
former Navy SEAL and the new head of an
anti-terrorist unit in the course of the
novel's plot Clark's unit has to deal
with several tariffs attacks around the
world and later even becomes the target
of fnatic Assassins as well there is
already a kind of prequel for the film
on Amazon Prime called without remorse
which was released in 2021 it tells the
prequel story of John Clark respectively
John Kelly as he is known by his real
name the film received mixed reviews so
we will have to wait to see whether the
sequel will prove to be more successful
a release date is not known as of yet
that's it with the news for this week
are you aware of any other hot news then
share them with the others here in the
comments and if you want to know more
about upcoming movies check out our new
original on the best upcoming superhero
movies in 2024 and 2025. then you'll
really be up to date on all of the new
upcoming Blockbusters thanks for
watching see you next time
foreign
[Music]